[Music]
hey you know about music means it's
final exam where we discover who ad Fox
has been paying attention to the news
before we begin though let us take a
quick look at last week's exam which was
a fiasco
as soon as Tucker us about Her Majesty
the Queen
which member of the royal family had the
world in hysterics this week when he or
she jokingly compared a noisy helicopter
to presidents Trump and Obama
congratulations a sitting u.s. senator
to do this while in office finish one
bonus question what is the capital of
Burkina Faso
can i chime in for sexual pandas that
was amazing
it's actually Brett and hers is Katie
but I'm gonna keep up the tradition and
call him Jeff I'm gonna call Katie Queen
what's-her-face masquerades bred from
fox news headlines 24/7 we've got the
back for a rematch we had problems the
the international quiz show arbitration
committee in Geneva said this won't pass
Massa bread license back along with
Katie Freight an editor in chief of the
daily walkthrough let's get to the
questions hands on buzzers I'm gonna ask
the questions and the first one to buzz
gets to answer you must wait until I
finish asking the question each correct
answer is worth one point
get it wrong you lose a point and the
best-of-five win so let's get started
question one this week after a 33 year
drought an American woman won which US
sporting event let's go to Brett the
Boston Marathon that well let us see you
roll tape let's see first American woman
to win the Boston Marathon since 1985 I
jumped the gun last time this week at
the National Zoo in Washington DC a baby
animal was born big news because he's
part of an endangered species so what
kind of animal is he where's Steve Irwin
not a panda well we know he's getting a
star on the Walk of
Masum ously think of the think of a
simian not a ruminant that's coming up
later but i big a big monkey yeah yeah
but is it correct roll that tape Oh baby
a new star is born at the National Zoo
after a western lowland gorilla gives
birth mother and baby doing just fine
that's the video they're bonding birds
update they're so cute though
yeah that's still in the lead over green
what's her face a new condiment in town
and folks seem to be very divided over
this Heinz is releasing a pre-mixed
mayonnaise and ketchup product for your
summer barbecues but what are they
naming this lethal combo brick
catcha neighs that is a fantastic name
but is it correct let's see mayo chip I
can't even say it correctly Mayo Twitter
Heinz tweeting quote we heard you saucy
Americans we're bringing you a version
of the duo that you've been already
eating years they should have called
ahead to me Heinz with you catcha days
so much better
in question four and and Brett is taking
a commanding lead here so the only
member of the Obama administration
considering a 2020 run for president
which other member of the Obama
administration confessed this week he's
also thinking of running Brett
no buts on a queen what's her name it's
Katie let's see if you're right back on
the board
earlier this week Holder said this about
a possible run focusing gerrymandering
and clean sweeping the nation
and it involves doing yoga with a farm
animal which four-legged animal is being
used in American yoga classes Katie
goats let's take a look at the tape yoga
which is exactly what it sounds like
Lotus poses and domesticated goats but
is it good for America or America's
goats there is nothing inherently wrong
with doing the downward dog pose next to
a goat
graduations really winning this pride a
genuine victory we've evolved as the
Eric Tucker mug and everyone's that's
all for this week pay attention to the
news each week and you too can be a
winner